from oil paintings blackened by tobacco
smoke to Broken century-old marble
statues from bucks ripping apart at the
seams to faded Italian murals these
items were in desperate need of repairs
we spoke with Specialists to find out
how they repair and restore
centuries-old works of art
[Music]
my name is Sarah Drew and I work as an
art conservator at center Art Studio in
New York City this is a portrait of mad
investories
[Music]
the first thing we do is inspect the
painting with a black light to
understand what all of the issues are so
you see the purple light and then you
see kind of like the greenish light that
indicates to us that there's like a
heavy thick old varnish on that surface
if there wasn't that you would just see
pure purple
you couldn't make out any sort of
contrast or light in the background the
ornament and the details on her clothes
were completely obscured there was
something on her head we weren't sure if
it was a hat or if it was hair when
you're running the Q-tip over the
painting it can be quite black or quite
orange or yellow depending on what
you're taking off
[Music]
her skin was beautiful it was bright it
had brush Strokes color contrast light
foreign
the first step of removing the painting
from the stretcher is to take out all of
the tacks that are holding the size of
the canvas onto the stretcher
I'll save them and I'm going to reuse
them later
you can see me using a knife to separate
the lining canvas fully from the
structure
[Music]
thank you
now comes the riskiest part separating
the painting from the stretcher you want
to be very careful because if the paint
is not stable uh you risk bending the
painting and causing flaking or further
damage
[Music]
I need to cut strips of linen and attach
them to the canvas so that I can then
put the whole piece back together again
I cut strips of Eva which is a
conservator's adhesive
foreign
[Music]
I then put the painting on the stretcher
and used tacks to reattach the painting
to its stretcher
then I filled with a water-based putty
areas of damage
[Music]
foreign
fill the areas a little bit
and then I come back in with a damp
cotton swab and clean up those fills
also the original canvas
doesn't extend quite to the edges of the
stretcher so I need to go and fill about
a quarter of an inch around the entire
perimeter of the painting
foreign
[Music]
I will begin the retouching process
I will use a paint that is specifically
designed for conservation work
[Music]
foreign
to
the color that the artist put there and
making sure that you're not painting
over any of that original paint
there's two types of in painting that I
will do here the first is in painting
over the fills that I just made the
second is in painting the background
and this is the area that was previously
over cleaned by the other restorer
is really important to use a
conservation paint that dissolves in a
solvent that is different than the
original paint
and this allows our paint to be
completely reversible we could easily
use that solvent to take off our paint
and then the original paint would be
unaffected then I will be ready for
varnish
foreign
[Music]
we use a completely reversible
non-yellowing varnish I need to wipe off
the surface of the painting or is it
just a cloth because
like anything it can accumulate little
particles of dust little hairs I want to
make sure that that surface is as clean
as possible
so once I wipe it off
I will brush on the varnish
when you brush on the varnish those
filled rotten painting it all kind of
Blends cohesively into the background
and into the surface of the painting and
it just looks complete
[Music]
foreign
the restoration is complete
[Music]
foreign
a portrait of Advent Holland that was
painted in 1895. this painting is an oil
on canvas and it is in a painted and
guilt wood frame both the painting and
the frame are extremely dirty the
painting has a very yellow varnish on
its surface and the frame has many
cracks and chips and loose areas that we
will fix so the first thing is to unbox
it when it arrives and to do an initial
assessment take note of any condition
issues and then you start the
deconstruction process we're going to
work on the painting in the frame
separately the painting is held into the
frame with nails so I use pliers to bend
the nails out and it's pretty easy there
were only a few of them I'm going to
work on restoring the painting my
colleague Karen is going to work on
restoring the frame so we bring the
frame into our wood room so Karen can
get started working on that I began and
by taking the painting off the stretcher
so in order to do this I remove the
tacks along the sides of the stretcher
that are holding the canvas tightly onto
the stretcher I use pliers to hold these
tacks out and that loosens the painting
and allows it to be a free piece of
canvas again when the painting comes off
the stretcher it's not uncommon for a
painting to not lie flat because it's
been held bent for you know decades so I
cut a piece of silicone release paper
and use a small tacking iron
to iron down the edges of the canvas so
it lays flat
I do an initial vacuum to remove all the
bulky loose obvious dust that is
accumulated on the back of the canvas in
the front of the canvas
after I vacuum I use a vulcanized rubber
sponge to remove more surface dust and
dirt that is a little bit more ingrained
into the surface of the canvas this is a
specially made sponge that is very
porous and pulls dirt off of surfaces
that might be slightly more ingrained
into the surfaces we use light pressure
with the sponge and we tend to go in a
straight lines as opposed to Circular or
scrubbing patterns
we do a surfactant cleaning to remove
grease and grime and oily substances off
the surface of the painting at this
point I'm still not doing anything to
affect the varnish or the underlying
paint or anything like that we use
cotton swabs dipped in a solution of the
surfactant soap and water typically wet
the swab and then wipe the swab in
typically circular motions over small
areas of the canvas at a time and this
is a very controlled way to remove the
sticky grimy substances that accumulate
on a painting surface over time the soap
solution also removed over paint from a
previous restorer there are a number of
Tears in the canvas that have been
repaired by somebody else and they were
not repaired very well so I removed all
that off
underneath the previous store I'd put a
layer of paper on the surface of the
painting which is an odd thing to do so
I used a scalpel to scrape that off but
between the heat gun and the scalpel we
can scrape off the paper and we will
repair these areas by patching them on
the back and using a putty to fill in
just the crack and make sure that we are
not covering over any of the original
paint once I've done my surfactant
cleaning I am ready to assess the
painting with a black light and do some
solvent tests to see what will cut
through the varnish and get down to the
original paint layer I use an
UltraViolet black light to assess the
surface and this light allows me to see
things that are going on under the
surface of the varnish that might not be
apparent to a naked eye I assemble
various solvents that I believe will be
contenders for cleaning and I do very
small chest cleanings in discrete areas
on the canvas to test and work out a
plan for cleaning the entire surface of
the canvas and I check my work with a
black light to make sure that what I'm
doing is working if I shine the black
light over my test cleaning I want to
see that that test cleaning window is
reflecting back purple that means that
I've cut through that varnish I've
gotten down to the original paint and
I'm it informs me and makes me feel
comfortable moving forward to work in
larger areas but similar to the
surfactant cleaning I use large cotton
swabs to work my way over the entire
surface of the painting and it's very
satisfying to see all the old yellow
varnish come off
I saved the face for last in this
instance uh mostly because it's the most
dramatic part of the cleaning process
and so it's good motivation to keep
going and we want to get to the face so
that's the most fun part to clean it
also became apparent once I removed all
the varnish that this painting which had
been treated by this other restorer had
been cleaned previously however it was
cleaned a little too aggressively so
there were areas where the original
paint had become thin so now I'm
realizing that I have a lot of maybe a
lot more retouching in my future than I
maybe anticipated
once the painting is clean we remove the
old patches and the old strip lining
canvas that's on the back of the
painting Lancing who is the owner of the
studio is doing this part A Lansing is
taking off the old patches and the old
strips to do this he uses a hot air gun
to heat up the patches and this loosens
up the old adhesive and allows Lansing
to take a bottle tool to lift off the
patch and we're left with the original
canvas we will strip line the edges of
the canvas this is so we will be able to
re-stretch the painting tightly onto the
stretch here
we cut strips of linen and adhere
conservators adhesive to the strips and
this is heat activated so we use an iron
to attach these strips to the back of
the original canvas we also will do the
same technique for the patches that on
the back and these patches will prepare
the rips that are in the canvas's
surface we glued Down The Frayed edges
of the strip lining so they also lay
flat against the original canvas Lansing
will re-stretch the painting onto its
original stretcher he marks the middle
of all four sides of the painting and
all four sides of the stretcher and then
he lays the loose canvas onto the
stretcher aligns the marks and then
Begins the stretching process he will
use a tacking hammer and the original
attacks that I removed earlier that we
saved to reattach the canvas to the
stretcher
now my colleague Tyler will be applying
a layer of isolation varnish to the
painting surface to protect all the
original paint and create a barrier
between the original paint and the paint
and materials that I'm going to apply
we're using a reversible non-yellowing
conservators varnish that's easily
removable we brush it onto the painting
surface all over and allow it to dry
at this point we put the keys in the
back of the stretcher and tap the keys
to make the surface of the painting
completely taut on the stretcher
once the canvas is taut we use a
water-based putty to fill the cracks in
the canvas surface and fill in any areas
along the edges or wherever it might
need to have a surface evened out I
select the colors that I expect I will
need for retouching we're using gambling
conservation piece these are paints that
are specifically designed for
conservation work and they're soluble in
solvents that are different than
solvents that will affect the oil paint
so again it's always very easy to remove
for whatever reason I mix the colors to
try to match the original color as best
as possible I'll put paint on the
surface if it looks correct I'll
continue if I need to alter it I will
one of the issues with this painting was
that it has been previously over cleaned
by another restorer to fix all this I
will remove the previous stores paint
and in paint in just those areas of loss
where it's thin with our own
conservation paint stippling very
carefully and very very very small areas
to make the painting look complete again
I'm very careful to only put this
conservation paint in the areas of floss
I never want to cover up any original
paint or do anything to obstruct the
original materials that the artists put
there I've been paint the entirety of
the canvas and we do a final coat of
varnish again
this final coat it's the moment of truth
it brings out all the work and once the
final layer of orange is on and it dries
the painting restoration is complete
so now there's the whole frame
restoration Karen does an all-over
vacuuming and then a sponge treatment of
the frame surface to remove any loose
dust now we clean the frame we use the
same surfactant soap that we use on the
painting surface
two of the four mitered corners on the
frame have very large gaps so we first
will use a epoxy putty to fill these
areas and then come in and fill over
that with a water-based putty we fill
the large ones it's always a judgment
call but we leave the smaller ones to
retain an element of age the ornament
detail on two corners of the frame are
missing we need to make a mold of the
ornament that does exist then we use a
plaster to actually cast a replacement
Karen glues them down onto the frame
does a little bit more shaping and then
we're ready to retouch the frame
once we have the frame retouched we
apply shellac to protect our work and
make sure it's all sealed now the
painting and the frame Restorations are
complete
we put the painting into the frame
and we hang the painting up on the wall
and
admire our work
[Music]
my team and I are going to walk you
through step by step how we restore a
250 plus year old French posture and
guilt wood frame this Frame was brought
to us by A Private Client along with a
painting that we will restore as well
the frame when it came to us was
extremely dirty and it needed a lot of
structural repairs there was a lot of
ornament that was missing
[Music]
when we start cleaning the frame we
start with the back there's a lot of
resin on the back of the frame so we use
a scalpel to scrape this resin off it's
likely some sort of polyurethane from a
previous restoration that stuff is
tricky to remove so mechanically
removing it with a scuffle is the best
approach
foreign
once we have the back clean we flip the
frame right side up and we start the
front cleaning
we commonly use cotton swabs to clean
the surface of a frame
but we also are going to be using micro
metal tools literally the same tools
that a dentist will use to really get
into all of the small little recesses
[Music]
we use a variety of solvents which lift
the dirt up and allow us to then take
swabs to lift the Dirt away
this Frame was originally water gilded
which means Gold Leaf was applied to it
because of that we have to be very
careful with our cleaning because it
would be very easy to remove that
original gilding
we never want to make something look
brand new
so while we are going into the recesses
and we are removing the dirt
we don't want to entirely remove all of
that built up patina we want to retain
an element of age
the main issue with the back of this
Frame is that it has been expanded to
take a larger piece of art than it was
originally built for
the first time we saw it we knew that we
were going to have to disassemble it and
build it back up properly
in order to put the frame back properly
we are using a product called fish glue
which is a super condensed fish product
it's a very traditional adhesive to use
in conservation and it's very strong
and then we align the frame
[Music]
once we feel that all the structural
work has been completed we move on to
filling in the missing areas of the
frame
three of the Four Corners are completely
missing their Corner ornament luckily we
have one corner that is completely
intact that works to our advantage in
this case because we will be able to
take a silicone mold of this corner and
then cast plaster replicas of it
[Music]
to make a mold off the frame we use a
silicone compound once you have it mixed
together you can lay it over a part of
the frame that you want to replicate
[Music]
it cures over the course of about 20 or
30 minutes
once it's fully cured you can carefully
peel it off the frame
[Music]
and you will have the imprint of the
shape of the frame that you want to
replicate in that mold
[Music]
we are using plaster to cast the molds
so we mix up a batch of plaster
and we pour it into the silicone mold
[Music]
once the plaster has dried we can pop
that out of the mold
[Music]
to prepare the frame to receive the
plaster casts we need to remove some of
the plastic material that's already on
it
we use a hammer and chisel to carve away
a recess that will allow the past piece
to sit flush in the frame
[Music]
we will shape and finesse these cast
pieces to make sure that they fit
properly in the areas where we're going
to be applying them
we use sandpaper in different grits
[Music]
we are using fish glue again to adhere
the cast pieces onto the frame
[Music]
when we feel like the frame is
physically complete it is time to move
on to the color work
the first layer of paint that we are
applying to the frame is a primer
this is a Venetian red primer and that
just creates a very nice red base layer
for us to work off of
[Music]
we are gold leafing the ornaments in the
corners of this fruit this is a process
called gilding
foreign
was originally gilded with cool teeth
and so whenever possible we like to use
the original materials in our
restoration just so the object has as
much Integrity to the original as
possible
the first step to gilding after you've
applied the base layer is to apply a
sizing medium
and this is brushed onto the plaster and
it is allowed to dry for about 30
minutes
it gets tacky and once it's tacky it's
in the right state to accept the gold
leaf
it is very very delicate so you can't
touch it with your hands it will just
crumble
so in order to handle it Karen one of
our team members is using a horse hair
brush and lay it onto the ornament that
we want to gild
we also will use squirrel hair brushes
to brush it on and make sure that it's
adhering to all of the recesses and all
of the areas of the frame
once the gold leaf is applied we move on
to the in painting process and we are
going to paint over the gold leaf to
tone it down slightly and also over all
of the fills that we've made on the
frame and we use a combination of
conservation colors which are paints
that are specifically designed for
conservation work
it is literally a trial and error
process often we will make a color we'll
have to adjust it correct it a little
bit
[Music]
this is where the frame starts to really
look like one whole object again
the next step is to apply a layer of
shellac and this just serves as a top
coat it protects all of our work it also
makes everything just have a cohesive
finish and Sheen
foreign
[Music]
we're really happy with how this
restoration came out we have done a lot
to restore the structural integrity and
the visual Integrity of this Frame and
we hope the client can enjoy the frame
for years to come
[Music]
I'm going to walk you through how my
team and I restore a 19th century
Italian marble sculpture and its
Alabaster base so it's been broken it's
been previously repaired it came to us
broken again this work of art is
comprised of four separate pieces that
includes the marble bust it's soccer
base and a pedestal which is in two
parts atop and a column
we're going to clean the bust the soccer
base and the pedestal components all
separately we start out on all of the
pieces by using a surfactant detergent
diluted in distilled water and spray it
onto the marble and the alabaster we
want to use what we need to properly
clean a piece but we never want to do
anything that's too harsh this
surfactant is very gentle and it lifts
the dirt off the surface kind of breaks
the surface tension between the dirt and
the surface and allows us to wipe or
swab away the accumulated surface dirt
and debris
the column is quite dirty and this is
because a pedestal column sits on the
floor and the dirt from the floor from
people's shoes it all gets brought up
onto that surface
we also use surfactant gels particularly
in areas that might be a little bit more
stubborn to clean
when we're storing something so old you
have to be mindful of the age of the
piece
so we never want to remove all of the
dirt out of all of the recesses and
completely remove the patina that's
built up on an item of age because that
would end up looking Incorrect and
inappropriate
so the top of the pedestal and the
sockle base that the bust sits directly
on have both been previously repaired
twice with the same types of glue we
need to entirely remove all of this old
adhesive that's not functional it's
yellowing it's not good for the marble
to have on its surface so we want to
make sure we get all of it off so we are
using a combination of scalpels
this is also a time where you have to be
very careful because Marvel is very
susceptible and alabaster is very very
susceptible to scratching so when you're
using those very sharp tools you want to
make sure that you are only scraping off
the glue and you're not accidentally
nicking the surrounding surface area
we use a number of visual aids to help
us in the conservation process one tool
that's very helpful is a small Spotlight
and this is a very direct targeted light
that allows us to very clearly see the
area that we are working on
we also use a black light which is very
useful because the UV light allows us to
see imperfections and residues on the
surface that are not visible to the
regular human eye
to attach the broken items back together
we are going to use a special
conservation epoxy it's called epotec
This is a two-part epoxy that you
combine together when you first mix it
it can be quite liquidy so we allow it
to sit for a little bit of time just to
develop a little bit more of a viscous
quality
we are going to permanently attach the
marble to the sockle base we're going to
reuse the original model Rod once we
have it at the right depth we put the
pin in the hole of the bust and we use
our epoxy pour that into the recess
then we put the base on the marble check
it for alignment front to back and left
to right and allow that to cure for a
little while
to ensure that the repair of the top of
the pedestal is extremely strong we are
going to pin the pieces in addition to
epoxying them we are going to take a
stainless steel rod stainless steel is
desirable because it's not going to rust
or change over time
we mark on the outside of the piece
where we're going to drill holes to take
the pins
and we are using our ancient drill press
once we have the holes we have the pins
we then can use our epoxy
to attach the two pieces back together
[Music]
we are going to fill the cracks in the
sculpture with plaster
we are applying the plaster with small
metal tools we tend to err on the side
of overfilling because it's very easy to
remove the posture material
the plaster cures quickly so you want to
make sure that you're getting enough on
while it's still workable
once we've filled the cracks and we've
allowed the plaster to fully dry we are
going to sand particularly the alabaster
base which had a large crack throughout
the entire thing we are going to sand
that down with different grits of
sandpaper
[Music]
in painting a marble sculpture is really
the same technique that we use for any
other sculpture or a painting we are
using our standard gambling conservation
colors we mix them up to get the right
color in this instance because the
marble and the alabaster are sort of
translucent it makes our job a little
trickier because we're trying to
replicate translucency on an opaque fill
in this instance you really can't mix
one color and apply it to the whole fill
you have to do thin washes of different
colors to mimic the texture and the
veining of the stone material
we are going to polish the alabaster
base and we use a very large polishing
wheel for this and we use Polishing
Compound applied to the wheel and that
Polishing Compound comes in a variety of
grits we use very fine ones in this
instance so it doesn't damage the
alabaster
foreign
the final step of the conservation is to
wax each piece of the sculpture so we
are using a very very fine micro
crystalline wax and we apply this over
the whole surface of each one of the
pieces allow it to dry for just a little
bit and then buff it off very gently
with soft cloths this wax is important
it not only makes the stone look good
visually it also serves as a protective
layer between the stone and the elements
once all of the components are complete
in their own right we do a final
assembly and this is how the piece will
be ultimately displayed at the client's
home
we are very satisfied with how the whole
piece came out we know the client loves
this piece and has had it broken for a
long time but you think she's going to
be very happy
[Music]
thank you
my name is Sophia Bogle I've been
restoring books for over 25 years and I
started my company save your books so
that anyone can learn archival book
repair
book I'm restoring today is the Hans
Christian Anderson fairy tales book from
the late 1800s early 1900s
foreign
the first thing that we do in pretty
much any full restoration is we have to
separate the cover from the text block
a tool that I prefer to use is the book
repair knife it has a rounded tip and is
less likely to do damage that you did
not intend as an exacto knife would
I'm removing the old tape it's very
acidic and if I leave it on the book at
all it's going to affect the book later
on
when you're removing some of the
original material and you know you're
going to be replacing it with something
it's good to Mark where it was in
relationship to the other materials and
so in this case I've used a pencil and a
piece of paper to Mark where the
original went
I'm using a 100 grit sanding block to
clean the edges of these boards off it
makes a nice clean Edge
[Music]
foreign
a lot of general cleaning can be done
using a book repair knife I'm using the
book repair knife to just remove some
clumpy bits that are stuck to the end
paper
when you're repairing a book usually all
the pages are still connected and there
are some pages that will benefit from
this washing technique that I have it'll
help us to get the tape off of the page
in a way that you couldn't do if it was
attached to the book still to wash a
page to get rid of the tape you just
have to put it in Fairly hot water
you aren't going to need any additives
to clean these Pages it's just hot water
it's surprisingly effective
it can sit in the water for hours
you're also just going to have to be
very delicate with the paper because
it's in a more delicate State when it's
in the water
I'm using a micro spatula to help
separate the pages and I'm also using a
ruler to help hold down the other page
[Music]
you can use a soft brush to help you to
brush away the old adhesive
[Music]
when you're touching up anything black
on a cover you're going to want to use
an archival pen it's the 0.08 Micron pen
and it is archival ink
the smaller the tip the better in a way
do not use a Sharpie those will damage
and discolor
[Music]
while I was cleaning I also noticed that
some of the guilt stamping has been
removed
when I'm using the word guilt guilt
refers to Gold so it's gold stamping on
the cover some people would call it
embossing
originally this was stamped with hot
metal plates with foil coming down onto
the book
the best way to fill in guilt stamping
is to use shell gold
I'm using a liner brush and I have all
the control in the world
you're gonna make mistakes you can
actually remove the guilt by using a
cuticle stick and then you can clean up
your guilt
[Music]
if you want to match the color of your
book and do touch up on the covers it's
not as hard as you might think you look
at this this is a greenish Brown
the brownish colors that tend to be on
these older books they they're muddy
looking and the way to get to that muddy
looking color is to go across the color
wheel from the color you think it is and
add that other color to make it more
muddy looking
[Music]
thank you
when you find tears on your pages and
you want to repair them I highly
recommend using Japanese tissue that's
thin and an archival paste such as what
I have here which is Nori paste it's a
rice starch paste a really thin tissue
is going to be better than a thicker
tissue you don't need very much paste
foreign
you get everything ready
you've got your book in the cover right
side up
[Music]
you're going to be gluing all of those
materials you're going to glue that Mull
and that little hinge and you're gluing
that decorative end shape back and then
you're going to close the cover
[Music]
and then you slip a sheet of wax paper
in
and then you put the pressing board in
that there were Pages missing from this
book I found a version of the story that
connected to where the book started with
the pages missing
I used paper that's called antique end
leaf
I am using a colored pencil to color the
edges of the new pages that I added to
the book I don't want them to pop out I
don't want it to look obvious that I
added these new pages
foreign that's our book
[Music]
hi my name is
the CEO and founder of trulio and it's a
it's a farm where it aims to produce a
top quality olive oil in Tuscany today
I'm going to walk you through how Marco
restores his beautiful 583 years old
fresco
the first work that we have to do is to
consolidate the walls the first thing is
they're really to take the stones that
are unstable take them off consolidate
whatever is underneath and then put the
stones back to their places
in this large Frisk there are cracks
here and there so the next step is to
consolidate these cracks the cracks gets
Consolidated with Rising special Rising
the next step is now to remove the
plasters that had been painted over the
Fresco in the last few centuries and to
do that Marco their starter needs to get
archaeological scalpel and remove every
single bits and pieces out of this huge
surface and there is a very delicate
work because if you are not precise
enough of course you can damage the
Fresco itself
foreign
now that the plaster has been removed we
can apply a Japanese paper soak with
water and ammonium carbonate this is a
very delicate process and the reason why
we are doing is because thanks to the
Japanese paper all the dirt and all the
external components get away from the
Fresco and there is a process that can
last up to six months after all this
work as you can see the Fresco is
revealing itself some of the colors are
now Vivid what was underneath the
plaster fortunately is still there for
most of it
we are actually applying again a
Japanese paper soaked with a different
product carbonate hydroxide and this is
a very important part of The Frisco
restoration because it stabilized the
the Fresco itself
now that all these processes are
completed Marco can start the second
phase of the restoration as you can see
there's a lot of gaps in the Fresco
because some of the paint has faded some
others were lost he's going to use a
very tiny small brush and he is going to
use a natural pigment like they were
used back in the 1400s there has been
the surveillance of the Italian
authority over this Fresco we are not
allowed in Italy to paint back anything
it is not present
foreign
took a long time I took 18 months we are
very proud that we didn't lose this
piece of art in Tuscany